john é um sonho que se sonha só é só o
sonho um sonho em que a gente é capaz de
agarrar a beleza ea esperança está por
trás do olhar de uma criança e um
adolescente de 19
essa grande periferia da florianópolis
ou na grande periferia da humanidade é a
capacidade da gente recuperar dentro a
essência da nossa vida e eu queria me
conectar neste momento com cada um com
cada uma que está aqui a gente retomar o
sonho se deixar de novo em chahr cá por
essa realidade que é o ser humano ser
humano é a realidade mais bela sobre o
planeta sobre a face da terra
agora milhões de seres humanos são
excluídos do mínimo de uma dignidade de
vida o sonho da significado a nossa
existência
o sonho da vida o sonho da coragem só
alimenta o sonho faz movimento
o sonho do sim parece o medo paralisa o
medo mata ea gente tem duas opções
permeada ao longo da nossa vida
ou a gente permite que o sonho flui o
agente fica e ato emparedado amedrontado
e não transforma
nossa capacidade de deixar a luz está
dentro brilhar
talvez o grande medo está dentro de nós
e não permitir que essa luz se domingo
portanto várias pessoas de vocês
ganharam um papelzinho
gostaria de pedir que vocês ascendesse o
celular no rosto de vocês bem diante do
rosto que a gente possa ver a beleza dos
rostos de vocês sem medo pouquinho mais
para frente
na frente do rosto gostaria quem está
sentado desce uma olhadinha na beleza
desses rostos dos olhos e cabelo dos
traços nesta cidade do mês de janeiro
até agora foram assassinados 126 jovens
cheios de sonho e foram abortados por
processo do emparedamento e do medo
vocês representam neste momento a 125
126 pessoas representam neste momento
podem se olharem esses jovens em que os
seus sonos sonhos foi abordado ao longo
de uma trajetória e de uma vida ainda
tão precoce
vocês representam pelo mapa da violência
da secretaria de segurança nacional 60
mil jovens nesse brasil que foram
assassinados no ano passado representam
60 mil em 2050
nós teremos nesse país uma juventude no
domingo
nós teremos nesse país um milhão
setecentos e sessenta mil jovens
assassinados
mas nessa tarde
eu quero trazer uma esperança ea nossa
capacidade de reverter esse processo de
construir nesse país uma oportunidade da
materialização do sonho da juventude e
vocês todos são jovens que estão aqui
agradeço podem desligar o celular e
podem sentar o sonho
ele passa por alguns caminhos na nossa
vida e no momento que nós somos capazes
de nos encharcar luz na pele do outro de
entrar na pele do outro e de romper com
o medo e não ter o outro como inimigo
nós somos capazes de entrar numa
comunicação e nos conectarmos na
construção de um sonho que se sonha
coletivamente nosso sonho na grande
florianópolis
nossas redes em cinco mil crianças
jovens e adolescentes todos os dias num
caminho que começa com dois meses e vai
até os bancos universitários e
materializar a beleza e 5 mil anualmente
é uma capacidade de mostrar que é
possível pensar esse caminho
agora eu queria dizer pra vocês como é
que a minha vida como um padre católico
da igreja católica um homem branco foi
capaz de dar uma guinada na sua vida
em 1979
eu estava cheio de teorias de coisas
lindas e bonitas de tantos livros lidos
de tantas discussões sobre transformação
social
porém não estava conectado com a pele de
um mundo que encharcou meu coração e que
até hoje não se desprende mais 1979
um belo dia de sol de manhã eu saio do
instituto teológico na cidade
universitária da trindade passos morros
ao redor e entrou no morro do mocotó é
um morro que comumente vem muito pelos
seus assassinatos pelas suas violências
na mídia
no entanto tudo ao contrário na entrada
do morro eu encontro uma pessoa e uma
bela pessoa dona claudete dona claudete
uma mãe de santo
essa pessoa me acolhe com largo sorriso
como sorriso que está aqui com suas mãos
e nós começamos a entrar junto e
construir um poço de água naquela
realidade e que ali eu comecei a incluir
a minha vida e fiz uma opção de mudança
e de morar nos morros onde habito até
hoje
e dentro desse processo num dia
dona claudete nos introduzir o seu
terreiro
e nós vamos numa noite da festa dos
orixás de preto velho com uma comida
enorme pelo chão afora tudo no chão
todos sentados e aí eu comecei a intuir
e agradeço a dona claudete até hoje
porque eu consegui ver a realidade da
periferia da realidade de 100 milhões de
homens e mulheres negros e negras nesse
país pela pele de dona claudete sentado
dentro do terreiro
os atabaques que tocavam aquele som que
entrava nos meus ouvidos
a coragem de me deixar entrar um sacro e
na sacralidade do sagrado que eu nunca
tinha visto imaginado e compartilhar com
aquela força do sagrado
as minhas entranhas a minha vida meu
encharcamento olhando toda aquela comida
partilhada que tinha no chão olhando
toda a força da ancestralidade olhando o
corpo daquelas mulheres nos seus ritmos
de dança
tudo isso começou a entrar dentro de mim
e é isso que me motiva
a dar continuidade na prática do meu dia
a dia na minha vida de construir redes e
leeds interativas treina que não fique
redes ilhados na periferia da grande
florianópolis dona claudete foi pra mim
essa intuição o terreiro foi pra mim
essa intuição o atabaque foi pra mim
a busca de ouvir essa ancestralidade que
é mais abandonada e abortada porque a
juventude mais assinada nesse país é a
juventude negra e aí comecei a entrar
nesse fio de caminho e aí eu digo
dentro desses processos da importância
dessa realidade que me tocou
profundamente e que me faz sonhar todo
dia e me dá gás todos os dias na minha
vida
e aí começamos um movimento de luta nas
periferias e aí dentro desse processo eu
comecei a olhar a beleza dos olhares das
crianças
a vivacidade a ternura
o encanto e comecei a fazer esse
contraste na medida que ia trabalhando
os jovens iam sendo assassinados e que
eu tinha visto antes e comecei a
entender de que se a violência é
apreendida a violência pode ser
desaprende da e se nesse brasil
a gente gasta milhões de dinheiro 700
mil encarcerados ea nossa proposta
continuamente é de encarceramento e de
judicialização da nossa juventude que
vem sendo massacrada a violência pode
ser desaprende da e aí começou todos os
projetos que hoje são sete organizações
com cinco mil crianças jovens e
adolescentes que hoje permeiam pululam
dentro desse processo das nossas redes e
chega até a universidade e que é um
ícone que é um caminho quando um jovem
termina a faculdade por exemplo de
medicina e volta a dizer eu te acolho
para um outro jovem eu te abraço
e eu faço com que tu chega até o final
da universidade é o sonho materializado
e aí materializar esse sonho com o
processo das redes e com o mundo do
voluntariado e com 340 pessoas que todos
os dias trabalham oito horas por dia nas
nossas organizações com uma força enorme
é a capacidade que a gente tem cada vez
mais de olhar essa realidade 80% da
nossa criançada só come salgado na hora
em que vem os nossos refeitórios e aí
dentro desses processos
eu queria contratar um pouco com o
dinheiro desse país que nós somos
corresponsáveis em repensar a realidade
que é o seguinte um adolescente e um
jovem custa para a genii no custo
benefício na área do preventivo 450
reais e um jovem que é tolhida sua
realidade e que ele vai pra um espaço
que suprime da sua liberdade
ele custa para o estado quatro mil e
duzentos reais
e aí eu pergunto diante dessa realidade
a onde investir
o processo e aí quando a gente vê essa
juventude que abandona as armas que saem
dessa realidade essa juventude passa a
mão numa prancha de surfe e deixarmos de
lado
em bremen é um outro caminho de vida dá
todo significado pra minha vida
diariamente
eu sou apaixonado por esse sonho porque
o meu sonho
no pequeno e no makro é que um dia na
grande florianópolis não tenha mais
nenhum jovem sendo assassinado
e nesse brasil não tenha mais nenhum
jovem sendo assassinado
por isso nessa tarde eu queria me
comunicar com a força mais vital que
está dentro de cada um de vocês estão
aqui que é tornar a vida de vocês uma
vida possível de olhar para os
horizontes de construir
unidades com essa juventude de entrar
nesse caminho de voluntariado de poderem
vir para os nossos espaços
nós temos mais de 500 voluntários
qual é o trabalho é uma relação de ida e
vinda em que a gente encurta o centro ea
periferia periferia e o centro e
constrói as oportunidades de espaços
cada vez mais dentro dessa perspectiva e
o voluntariado é fundamental porque é
possível tirar da invisibilidade
traseiro visível é possível transformar
e se transforma com tom pouco e essa
população de periferia organizada
começou a pensar que tem de mais longe
tende para a áfrica amanhã a áfrica é o
hábito no morro
noventa por cento da população é negra e
uma mãe pegou um cofrinho encheu de
moedinhas e dali nasceu um outro projeto
nosso
nós estamos trabalhando em guiné bissau
com 1324 crianças e que foi tão fácil
porque uma criança na áfrica para
estudar o ano inteiro ela custa apenas
300 reais ao ano ea gente materializa
para chegar à universidade e
materializar o sonho
vejam que aqui nasci eu queria
encerrando a minha fala com vocês e
fazendo uma grande convocação para que
nessa tarde a gente pudesse ou nesses
tempos em que a gente vive resgatar uma
dimensão mais profunda do ser humano que
a dimensão da solidariedade
solidariedade não é um decreto
solidariedade não são teorias
solidariedade é quando a gente sai das
nossas ilhas das nossas áreas de
conforto ea gente se deixa se encharca
pela pele dessa criançada e aí a gente
começa a descobrir de que vale a pena
trabalhar pelo sorriso
os meninos das meninas do shopping vale
a pena quando a gente sobe e desce mo ea
juventude
incluía universidade eu estou empregado
abre um outro caminho
a solidariedade é essa capacidade nossa
que nasce dentro do coração retomar e
evocar a força do espírito está dentro
de nós
desse respiro que a gente respira todo
dia de que é possível transformar o
mundo de que é possível transformar a
realidade das periferias que é possível
transformar este continente ea
humanidade
basta que a gente olhe para os lados que
a gente abraça a gente se conecte pelos
olhos que a gente sente do lado sentada
do lado do outro ea gente abre espaço e
gostaria de convidá-los para essa grande
ciranda que a ciranda da justiça social
a solidariedade da época da
materialidade do sonho de tantos meninos
e meninas que talvez a gente possa
diminuir essa dimensão dos assassinatos
gerar vida vida com dignidade
e aí eu queria dizer a cada um se cada
um de vocês que está aqui adotasse um
menino um jovem e um adolescente para
acompanhar o seu caminho
se você saísse daqui e começasse a dizer
nós queremos e da periferia
nós queremos transformar essa cidade se
cada um de vocês que estivesse aqui
pudesse dizer que a gente leva junto eu
quero ir para a áfrica ajuda a
transformar lá me colocar à disposição
todo o conhecimento que a gente aprendeu
nos bancos escolares não em nosso todo o
conhecimento que a gente aprendeu nas
universidades não é nosso é do público
ea gente tem de ajudar a construir essa
casa comum
por isso eu agradeço a cada um por essa
conexão
mas por essa vocação porque eu vou sair
daqui de novo inchar kato apaixonado
pela importância de fazer com que o ser
humano
descubra o quanto ele pode ser amado e o
quanto a gente pode materializar de um
sonho possível
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]